welcome back everybody silver state
schools credit union the sponsors of
this next segment is growing we checked
in with them to get more details
[Music]
i'm scott r kills president and ceo of
silver state schools credit union and
we're here in our board room today where
we plan everything that assists our
members we have some exciting news we
have two branch openings our aliante
branch will be moving out of its
in-store location and opening at a new
location in the same plaza on monday
september 13th this move is going to
allow us to better serve our members
with a full service branch lobby for
more private banking experience we have
complete details available on our
website at silverstatecu
we are also proud to announce the
opening of our newest in-school branch
at the southeast career technical
academy also known as sector high school
so this first of a kind high school
branch will offer sector students a
place to manage all their banking needs
as well as learn about a career in the
banking industry this integration allows
us to reach the youth in our community
and guide them through a path to
financial success we're committed to
supporting education in the future of
our young students in nevada so it's our
plan to have more branches like this in
clark county school district
high schools in the future we're going
to add three more in the future and so
we're very excited about that and with
schools up and running i want to make
sure that everyone knows about our
commitment to education and to find
financial literacy for all of our
members on our website we have free
financial literacy tools that anyone can
use people using financial literacy
tools can learn about a wide variety of
topics that will set you on a path to
financial success everything from
savings credit cards building emergency
funds budgeting tools buying a home
buying a car and financing that car
right there on the website at
silverstatecu.com
you owe it to yourself to learn more
about how to navigate your finances
there are videos and simple lessons and
frequently asked questions about each
topic the common misconception is that
we only allow educators to become
members and that's not true almost
anyone can become a member of silver
state school's credit union volunteers
trustees board members of any
educational institution and their family
members are all eligible for membership
students parents or guardians of
students are also eligible for
membership at silver state schools
credit union and if you don't have a
connection to the education system at
all you can simply make a nominal
one-time donation to vegas pbs and
become a member we want to be inclusive
while still being committed to our
education community so please visit our
website for more information on how you
can become a member today you can apply
for membership by stopping at any of our
10 branch locations here in the las
vegas valley where a member service
representative would be very happy to
help you or you can visit our website
again and apply online at
silverstatecu.com
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring this segment for
more information just call
702-733-8822 or visit
silverstatecu.com kendall thank you